hello everyone i'm dr umar malik and
welcome to math simplified
vitamin d also known as the sunshine
vitamin is a big topic right now
it comes as a surprise for most people
because they have never really had a
problem before and most of us believe
that a low vitamin d level change is
nothing
and it will not be a problem for us
anytime soon
well now vitamin d deficiency and
insufficiency is a global public health
problem
a conservative estimate tells us that
more than 1.3 billion people worldwide
are deficient for vitamin d
so in this video we will talk about how
vitamin d deficiency is a serious issue
and why you must take active steps to
treat vitamin d deficiency
vitamins are considered as essential
nutrients because either your body
cannot make them or they are made in
inadequate amounts they prevent negative
health consequences or diseases and are
vital for the optimum functioning of our
body
but vitamin d is special unlike other
vitamins it can be made by our body when
exposed to sun hence the name sunshine
vitamin
an estimated 80 of our total vitamin d
in our body comes from sun exposure to a
skin terms like crickets and
osteomalacia are commonly thrown around
when you talk about vitamin d deficiency
but research and years of clinical
experience has shown that the health
consequences of vitamin d deficiency not
only affects the bones but has far
reaching consequences for the whole body
researchers have found an alarming
number of health issues outside of its
role with bone diseases these include
certain cancers obesity and
cardiovascular diseases autoimmune
diseases
certain infections including covet 19
inflammatory bowel diseases and mental
health issues including various
psychological and cognitive disorders
so keeping that in mind let's start from
the very beginning
let's look at what are the common causes
of vitamin d deficiency the reasons vary
from insignificant causes like
inadequate exposure to sunlight and more
serious conditions like kidney and liver
problems
number one dark skin color melanin is
what gives skin its color
light skin people have less melanin than
those with darker skin
melanin is important because more
melanin means darker skin and darker
skin means natural sun protection
however as less sunlight can cross the
skin
dark skinned individuals require at
least three to five times longer
exposures to make the same amount of
vitamin d as a person with a white skin
tone research has also proven that
african american population has a mean
vitamin d level less than that of white
americans
number two is limited exposure to the
sun this is by far one of the most
common reasons of vitamin d deficiency
today as industrialization progressed we
tend to spend more time indoors most
adults work indoors and wear more
clothing during the work week which
leaves only minimal of the body exposed
to sunlight for short periods so they
cannot meet their vitamin d needs
through the sun alone
even if you do have some exposure to the
sun the total amount of vitamin d you
can produce is affected by many factors
like the season time of the day ozone
amount latitude and the number of clouds
in the sky
additionally increased awareness of skin
cancers has led to an incremental rise
in the use of sun protective creams
which are known to decrease the vitamin
d synthesis process
number three is being overweight or
obese
being overweight or obese may put you at
a risk for vitamin d deficiency a recent
review of 23 studies has shown that
obese people had 35 higher rates of
vitamin d deficiency compared with the
normal weighted subjects
while diet and decreased sun exposure
may have some impact on this there
appears to be an increased need that
cannot be met without a supplement
number four mal absorption and unhealthy
diet
people who have nutritionally
underwhelming and insufficient diets are
at a higher risk of developing vitamin d
deficiency
also people with a history of previous
gut surgeries unhealthy gut and
malabsorption syndromes for example
crohn's or celiac disease are often
unable to absorb enough vitamin d from
their diet which leads to a deficiency
number five is certain medications and
medical conditions
a wide variety of medications including
antifungal medications anticonvulsants
steroids and medications to treat aids
in hiv can enhance the breakdown of
vitamin d and lead to its low levels
also conditions like liver failure and
kidney failure interfere with the body's
natural pathways of synthesizing vitamin
d
if you are interested in learning more
about how our body synthesizes vitamin d
and how vitamin d acts in our body we'll
be uploading a video sometime soon so
make sure to subscribe to our channel
and hit the bell icon
well now that we know why vitamin d
deficiency occurs we can now ask the
question what are the health risks of
vitamin d deficiency
looking back in the mid 1600s two
gentlemen by the name of whistler and
glsen reported that children living in
industrialized cities in great britain
had short stature and had deformities of
the skeleton especially of the lower
legs a disease well known today as
ricketts which occurs due to the vitamin
d deficiency in children
however it wasn't until 1889 that
physicians discovered that sunbathing
was important for preventing rights
since then many other health benefits of
vitamin d and risks associated with
deficiency have been reported let's take
a look at a few of these
number one are skeletal diseases now
this is a common knowledge that vitamin
d is important for your bones but how
exactly that happens is as follows
vitamin d enhances the absorption of
calcium and phosphorus in your diet and
without it only 10 to 15 percent of
calcium and phosphorus are absorbed from
your diet thus vitamin d maintains the
optimum blood calcium levels to enable
your bones to remain healthy and strong
vitamin d deficiency leads to bone loss
osteopenia osteomalacia osteoporosis and
eventually increased risk of fractures
also there are vitamin d receptors in
human muscles that have a direct effect
on muscle strength this is evident from
the fact that severe vitamin d
deficiency can cause myopathy or
abnormal muscle function which can cause
muscle weakness and pain
treating vitamin d deficiency in elderly
population has been shown to decrease
knee and hip pain
a study of 769 older adults aged 50 and
80 years found that moderate vitamin d
deficiency positively predicts the
incidence of worsening of knee pain and
possibly hip pain over the next two to
five years
number two autoimmune diseases
autoimmune diseases are those disorders
in which the body's defense mechanism
misfires and starts acting out against
the body's own cells
now where exactly does vitamin d fit in
the case of autoimmune diseases is
unclear but there has been research that
shows a definitive link between vitamin
d deficiency and developing autoimmune
disorders
now take for example the case of type 1
diabetes in finland
type 1 diabetes is also an autoimmune
disorder the recommended daily dosage of
vitamin d was gradually reduced from
4000 units per day in 1964 in finland to
400 units per day in 1992. during this
period the incidence of type 1 diabetes
increased by more than 350 percent in
children aged between one to four years
even more convincing data came in 2006
when finland authorities made it
mandatory for all dietary milk to be
fortified with vitamin d2 and following
which the incidence of type 1 diabetes
platitude and begin to decrease
similarly current evidence supports that
vitamin d deficiency increases the risk
of developing multiple sclerosis which
is another autoimmune disease and
vitamin d supplementation alters the
disease activity in people with multiple
sclerosis
also a review of studies shows that in
people with multiple sclerosis having
adequate levels of vitamin d were
associated with fewer lapses
also they had lower risk of development
of new lesions in the brain had lesser
disability and lesser disease severity
and better long-term memory
number three cancer
cancer is a dreadful disease and
unfortunately we are still struggling to
fight it effectively years after years
of research have tried to isolate the
various risk factors that potentially
cause cancers in humans
one such risk factor being studied is
vitamin d deficiency a number of studies
have investigated whether people with
higher vitamin d intakes or higher blood
levels of vitamin d have lower risks of
specific cancers the results of these
studies however have been inconsistent
but these studies have suggested that
there may be an association between
increased risk of various cancers for
example colon cancer breast cancer
ovarian cancer skin cancer and prostate
cancer among people who are living far
from the equator
since these people get fewer sunlight
exposure to the skin they have an
increased prevalence of vitamin d
deficiency
number four cardiovascular diseases also
known as heart diseases
the term cardiovascular not only refers
to the heart but also to the conductive
vessels that help the heart push blood
to the whole body namely the arteries
veins and capillaries
a review of six studies that included
over 6400 people found that patients
with cardiovascular disease who
additionally had lower levels of vitamin
d
had more severe and advanced diseases
compared to those who had optimum levels
of vitamin d
vitamin d deficiency is associated with
an increased risk of hypertension that
is high blood pressure
also hyperlipidemia also known as high
cholesterol peripheral vascular diseases
coronary heart rate diseases myocardial
infarction or heart attack heart failure
and stroke the anti-inflammatory effects
of vitamin d may be the reason for this
and studies are ongoing to examine this
relationship
number five increased prevalence of
infections
it's possible that maintaining adequate
vitamin d levels could lessen the length
and severity of upper respiratory tract
infections and possibly even prevent
them
this was proven by a review of 12
studies including
2279 children
the study found that children with lower
respiratory infections had significantly
lower vitamin d levels compared with
normal healthy children
also there was a relationship between
how low the vitamin d level went and how
severe the infection was
this is especially important in the
current scenario of koved a latest study
in israel had surprising results the
researchers found that being deficient
in vitamin d before contracting covid19
had a direct impact on how severe the
disease will be and eventually how
lethal it became
the study revealed that 26 of the people
who had a pre-infection deficiency or
vitamin d diet compared to only three
percent of those who had higher levels
of vitamin d a staggering difference of
23 percent
while the researchers do not point to
vitamin d deficiency as being the cause
of death it states that if vitamin d
levels were low the disease was severe
and there was increased mortality in an
independent manner
whether or not vitamin d supplementation
helps in covet 19 is still understudy
however the author of the study says
that it is vital that people maintain a
healthy level of vitamin d in their body
as it may help them fight against
scovid19 infection
well friends with this we come to the
end of this video stay tuned for more
such content and leave a like or a
comment if you'd like to know more about
vitamin d
you can also consider becoming a member
on our youtube channel or support us via
patreon
do comment in the comment section below
for some topics for you like to make us
a video about
we at mad simplified are committed to
bringing you the latest content
till then take care stay safe and do
treat yourself to some good sunshine
every now and then